[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den Sport ein schönen guten Abend
fünf Wissenschaftler haben Deutschlands
Klimapolitik geprüft
so wird das nichts mit den Klimazielen
der Expertenrat sagt die Maßnahmen der
Bundesregierung reichen nicht aus
ein Gipfel gegen den Westen China Indien
und Co treffen sich in Südafrika
russlands Präsident Putin wird
zugeschaltet
und tickende Zeitbomben in der Ostsee
mit maroden alten Öltankern unterläuft
Russland die Sanktionen
[Musik]
mehr als 130 Maßnahmen zum Klimaschutz
hat die Bundesregierung eingeleitet doch
die seien unzureichend sagt der
offizielle Expertenrat für Klimafragen
die Koalition müsse mehr tun und
überschätze ihre eigenen Anstrengungen
selbst wenn alle Maßnahmen tatsächlich
umgesetzt werden würden die Ziele nicht
erreicht laut Klimaschutzgesetz muss
Deutschland seinen Ausstoß an
Treibhausgasen bis 2030 um mindestens 65
Prozent im Vergleich zu 1990 senken
aktuell sind gut 40 Prozent erreicht
besonders im Bereich Gebäude etwa beim
Heizen passiert zu wenig noch größere
Defizite gibt es beim Verkehr Karl
Hinterleitner
das Urteil war vernichtend kein
realistischer Zeitplan keine
ausreichende Überprüfung kein
schlüssiges Konzept die
Expertenkommission geht mit dem
Klimaschutzprogramm der Bundesregierung
hart ins Gericht es gebe nicht einmal
verlässliche Daten
die Regierung hat uns ein Puzzle mit
1000 Puzzleteilen gegeben sind auch 1000
Teile aber wir haben da festgestellt die
bestehen aus drei verschiedenen puzzeln
und jetzt haben wir hier ein Stück und
da ein Stück und da ein Stück ein
wichtiger Punkt für den Expertenrat die
Gebäudesanierung hier ließe sich viel
CO2 einsparen die Umsetzung aber stockt
das Hin und Her beim Gebäude
Energiegesetz habe für so große
Unsicherheit gesorgt dass kaum jemand in
den Klimaschutz investiere stellt die
deutsche Bauwirtschaft fest was im
Moment fehlt sind die Aufträge und ich
glaube da liegt auch ein bisschen das
Thema so wie beim heizungsgesetz vor der
Sommerpause in der Politik dass wir im
Moment nicht wissen was müssen wir zu
welchem Zeitpunkt bauen Häuslebauer
Investoren die Mietwohnungsbau aber auch
Hauseigentümer wussten nicht wann gilt
was welche Heizung muss ich einbauen
welche Heizung kann ich einbauen welche
Förderung gibt es die Spielregeln waren
völlig unklar besonders viel Emissionen
entstehen im Verkehr der Sektor hängt
laut Expertenrat bei den
Klimaschutzzielen am meisten hinterher
das könne und müsste man ändern jemand
meint die Deutsche Umwelthilfe wir
brauchen ein Tempolimit damit alleine
könnten 11 Millionen Tonnen CO2 pro Jahr
eingespart werden oder natürlich auch
ein Abbau der klimaschädlichen
Subventionen wie das Dienstwagen
Steuerprivileg oder des dieselprivileg
eins muss man ganz klar sagen nichts zu
tun in Sachen Klimaschutz wird richtig
teuer wird für uns alle teuer wir werden
Strafzahlungen leisten müssen alles in
allem einer eher schlechte Bilanz für
das Klimaschutzprogramm der Regierung
die Pläne ambitioniert die Umsetzung
bisher mangelhaft
wie es gehen kann zeigt die Gemeinde
Simmerath in der Eifel sie produziert
viel mehr Strom als sie selbst braucht
mit Windkraft erstaunlicherweise gab es
gegen diesen Windpark kaum Widerstand
wohl auch weil die Energiequelle die
Gemeindekasse füllt und die Bürger von
niedrigen Steuern profitieren heute
kamen der Bundeskanzler und der
Ministerpräsident torgebode berichtet
22 Windräder stehen in Simmerath und
obwohl es kaum Proteste gab dauerte der
Bau der Anlage noch immer 6 Jahre am
Vormittag informiert sich der Kanzler
über das Projekt und verspricht
Gesetzesänderungen um schneller beim
Wind energieausbau voranzukommen wir
werden gleichzeitig aber auch viele
mutige entscheiderinnen Entscheidern auf
allen Ebenen Deutschland brauchen die
nicht für alles ein Gutachten brauchen
sondern einfach sagen ich entscheide
jetzt in Simmerath haben sie das getan
von Anfang an waren die Einwohner in die
Planung des Windparks einbezogen
inzwischen produziert die Gemeinde
184% ihres Stroms aus Windkraft der
erzeugte Energieüberschuss spült in
diesem Jahr rund 2 Millionen Euro in den
Haushalt außerdem wie viel beachten die
Flächen und bekommen Gewerbesteuer haben
und andere Einnahmen auch noch dazu und
dieses Geld brauchen wir nicht mehr von
den Bürgern und deshalb haben wir bei
uns in Simmerath mit Abstand die
geringsten Grundsteuer und Gewerbesteuer
und unsere Region das Beispiel Zimmerer
zeigt wie man Kommunen bei der
Energiewende mitnehmen kann denn sie
spielen eine entscheidende Rolle sei es
durch die Ausweisung von Bauflächen oder
bei der Akzeptanz der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger man sieht die Vorteile von mehr
Strom grünen Strom vor Ort für Bürger
aber auch für Unternehmen und sprechend
wachsen Kommunen auch in eine neue Rolle
hinein nämlich eine unterstützende Rolle
eine
gestaltende Rolle in der Energiewende in
Simmerath wünschen sie sich weniger
Bürokratie um noch schneller beim Wind
energieausbau voranzukommen denn die
nächsten 10 Windräder sind schon geplant
jetzt zu einer Gruppe die nichts
Geringeres will als die Welt zu
verändern als politisches und
wirtschaftliches Gegengewicht zum Westen
die brix-staaten
Brix das steht für fünf große
aufstrebende Volkswirtschaften Brasilien
Russland Indien China und Südafrika
zusammen machen sie etwa 40% der
Weltbevölkerung aus und ein Viertel der
globalen Wirtschaftsleistung zum 15 Mal
sind sie nun zusammengekommen aus
Johannesburg
Gipfel hat begonnen am Abend zeigen sich
zumindest drei der Staatschefs aus
Südafrika Brasilien und Indien werden
für eine Neuordnung des internationalen
Wirtschaftssystems
wir brauchen eine grundlegende Reform
der globalen Finanzinstitutionen so dass
sie besser auf die Herausforderungen der
sich entwickelnden Länder reagieren
können
noch vor Beginn hatte Gastgeber
Südafrika den chinesischen Präsidenten
empfangen der Wirtschaft macht China
kommt in der brix-gruppe eine
Führungsrolle zu
massiv hat das Land in Afrikas
Infrastruktur investiert wie hier in
Kenia Straßenbahnstrecken und Häfen
gebaut
wir sind dankbar dafür was die Chinesen
schon hier gemacht haben es gibt den
Kenia eine große Entwicklung und das
finden wir gut
das Ziel der bricks-
Hauptthema des Gipfels wird eine
mögliche Erweiterung der bricks starten
sein doch nach welchen Kriterien neue
Länder aufgenommen werden sollen ist
innerhalb der Gruppe umstritten fest
steht der Westen wird sich mit dem
gestiegenen Selbstbewusstsein der bricks
beschäftigen müssen
der russische Präsident hätte sich
sicher gerne im Kreis der Staats- und
Regierungschefs gezeigt Armin Körper in
Moskau was bedeutet es für Putin nicht
dabei zu sein
der Präsident des größten Landes der
Welt nicht an diesem Gipfel teilnehmen
kann weil ihm dort die Festnahme droht
ich denke das kann man nur als Blamage
bezeichnen vor etwa einer Stunde hat
Präsident Putin sich per Videobotschaft
an die Gipfel Teilnehmer gewandt in
seiner Rede hatte einmal mehr die
Sanktionen gegen sein Land als illegal
gebrandmarkt und die sein verantwortlich
für den Hunger in der Welt er fordert
einen fairen Welthandel abseits der
Dollar Dominanz und er sagt der Handel
zwischen den brix-staaten sehr allein im
ersten Halbjahr dieses Jahres um über
30% gewachsen Russland braucht neue
Handelspartner Russland braucht vor
allem Importe um den Verfall der Währung
aufzuhalten und Russland braucht
Komponenten und Rohstoffe vor allem für
die Rüstungsindustrie die heutige Rede
putin war vor aufgezeichnet
währenddessen traf er sich hinter mir im
kremme mit den Vertretern des Rates für
nationale Stra Energien ich denke man
kann das durchaus interpretieren dass er
den anderen nicht zugehört hat auch weil
er eben an dem Gipfel persönlich nicht
teilnehmen kann danke für diese
Einschätzung aus Moskau Armin Körper war
das
vertiefendes zum Treffen in Johannesburg
sendet ZDF heute live um 19 Uhr 30
außerdem haben wir online einen
Vergleich zwischen dem bricksverbund und
dessen gegen Pol den G7 Staaten und
Infos über die Interessen Chinas in der
brix-gruppe jederzeit auf der ZDF heute
App
auch Griechenland wird ukrainische
Piloten an F16 Kampfjets ausbilden das
Land stehe an der Seite der Ukraine
sagte Premierminister mit zur Tages beim
Besuch von Präsident selensky in Athen
die ausgebildeten Piloten werden dann
die versprochenen dänischen und
niederländischen F16 fliegen die ersten
Kampfjets sollen zum Jahreswechsel in
die Ukraine geliefert werden
als Reaktion auf den russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine hat der
Westen ja umfangreiche Sanktionen
verhängt die Idee Moskau soll etwa seine
Rohstoffe nicht mehr einfach auf dem
Weltmarkt anbieten können nach
Recherchen des zdf-magazins frontal
umgeht Russland die handelssperren in
der Ostsee mit Hilfe schrott-schiffe
Michael haselrieder berichten
unterwegs auf der Ostsee vor der
estnischen Küste wir sind auf der Suche
nach der sogenannten schattenflotte
wollen wissen wie Russlands Ölgeschäfte
laufen trotz EU-Sanktionen in Sichtweite
heute 11 Tanker einer davon die Limo
registriert in Kamerun Baujahr 2000 also
über 20 Jahre alt und ja das ist ein
Schiff bei sich auch sichtbar in einem
sehr schlechten Zustand befindet überall
Rost und dieses Schiff fährt russisches
Öl über die Ostsee auf die Weltmeere
experten rechnen solche Tanker einer
Schatten Flotte zu mit wechselnden Namen
und verschleierten Besitzern rund 2000
Ozean riesen sollen unter billigflagge
auf den Weltmeeren fahren seit den
Sanktionen steuern sie immer häufiger
russische ölhäfen in der Ostsee an
ustuga und
primaski war früher Außenminister
Estlands heute betreibt er ein Hotel
es wäre eine Katastrophe für die Ostsee
wenn ein rostiger Tanker
auseinanderbrechen würde und das kann
passieren wenn sie nicht inspiziert
werden
schon vor einem Jahr konnte frontal vor
der griechischen Küste dokumentieren wie
Sanktionen umgangen werden Öl wird von
russischen Tankern auf andere Schiffe
gepumpt zurück auf der Ostsee dort
tauchen plötzlich ein russisches U-Boot
und ein russisches Kriegsschiff auf dann
zeigt sich auch die estnische
Küstenwache für uns das Zeichen
zurückzukehren
mehr zur schattenflotte in der Ostsee
zeigt frontal heute um 21 Uhr
rund 12 Jahre nach dem Super-GAU im
japanischen Atomkraftwerk Fukushima will
der Betreiber ab Donnerstag
aufbereitetes Kühlwasser ins Meer leiten
täglich etwa 500.000 Liter das Vorhaben
ist umstritten japanische Fischer
befürchten Einnahme Einbußen laut
internationaler Atomenergiebehörde sind
die Gefahren für Mensch und Umwelt aber
vernachlässigbar bevor das Wasser ins
Meer geleitet wird sollen dem Betreiber
zufolge fast alle radioaktiven
Bestandteile herausgefiltert werden
2011 war es im Atomkraftwerk nach einem
Erdbeben und einem Tsunami zur
Kernschmelze gekommen
Teile Südeuropas kämpfen weiter mit
extremer Sommerhitze die Wetterdienste
in Frankreich und Italien haben für
zahlreiche Städte und Regionen die
höchste hitzewarnstufe ausgerufen im
Rontal werden mehr als 40 Grad erwartet
knapp darunter Rom Florenz und 14
weitere italienische Städte hier können
die Behörden nun Veranstaltungen absagen
und öffentliche Einrichtungen schließen
in vielen Teilen Griechenlands haben
Hitze und Wind die Waldbrände dramatisch
verschlimmert auch auf einer Müllkippe
nahe der Hauptstadt Athen brach ein
Feuer aus von den Waldbränden besonders
stark betroffen ist die Hafenstadt
alexandropolis im Nordosten in einem
Nationalpark nahe des Ortes avantas
wurden 18 Tote gefunden vermutlich
Migranten Christian Volk berichtet
Alexandros und seine Familie können nur
noch zusehen seit vier Tagen breiten
sich die Flammen bei avantas aus immer
weiter immer schneller angefacht von
heftigem Wind das Feuer hat unser Dorf
erreicht unser Haus stand dort oben wo
die Flammen ausgebrochen sind alles ist
niedergebrannt
mehr als 200 Feuerwehrleute sind im
Einsatz sie kämpfen um jeden
Quadratmeter denn die Brände Rücken an
die Hafenstadt Alexandroupolis heran
dort leben rund 70.000 Menschen bereits
jetzt mussten die Behörden das
Universitätsklinikum der Stadt
evakuieren die Patienten etwa auf einer
Fähre in Sicherheit bringen
so etwas habe ich noch nicht erlebt es
fühlt sich an wie im Krieg überall
verstreute tragen Patienten hier
Patienten dort
die Flammen zerstören alles was ihnen in
den Weg kommt bei avantas finden die
Retter 18 verbrannte Leichen offenbar
Flüchtlinge
in der Region sind keine Anwohner als
vermisst gemeldet deshalb untersuchen
wir die Möglichkeit dass es sich um
Menschen handeln könnte die illegal ins
Land gekommen sind
und nicht nur im Nordosten des Landes
brennt es auch eine Region nahe der
Hauptstadt Athen ist betroffen und pro
Stunde kommen durchschnittlich drei neue
Waldbrände hinzu
im Nordwesten Pakistans spielt sich seit
Stunden ein Drama in einer Seilbahn ab
sechs Schulkinder und zwei Erwachsene
sind mit einer Gondel stecken geblieben
hunderte Meter über einer Schlucht und
nur noch an einem Stahlseil hängend in
einer riskanten Rettungsaktion gelang es
inzwischen kurz vor Anruf der Dunkelheit
mehrere Kinder zu befreien in den Bergen
Pakistans sind Seilbahnen auf das
einzige Transportmittel immer wieder
gibt es tödliche Unfälle
die Massenschlägereien im Ruhrgebiet im
Juni waren ein Beleg für die
Gewaltbereitschaft krimineller Clans wie
sehr diese klaren Kriminalität zunimmt
zeigen jetzt neue Zahlen aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen dort wurden im
vergangenen Jahr
6573 Straftaten mit klaren Bezug
registriert
20,3% mehr als im Vorjahr etwa ein
Drittel der Straftaten waren laut
Landeskriminalamt sogenannte
Rohheitsdelikte wie
raubkörperverletzung oder
Freiheitsberaubung
ob es regnet oder die Sonne scheint das
Wetter interessiert alle doch für eine
Berufsgruppe bestimmt es entscheidend
das Geschäft für die Bauern und das Jahr
2023 hatte es nicht nur gut gemeint mit
der Landwirtschaft es gab nasse Perioden
aber auch viel Trockenheit nicht immer
alles zum richtigen Zeitpunkt
entsprechend fällt auch die Ernte aus
Jan Meyer hat sich umgehört
die Getreideernte ist abgeschlossen auf
dem Feld wird bereits der Winter Raps
fürs nächste Jahr ausgesät Peter Bremer
ist enttäuscht von der Qualität des
Roggens in diesem Sommer nach einem
trockenen Frühling hat Starkregen die
Ernte beeinträchtigt der Roggen wird
auch kein brotrocken mehr sondern es
werden wahrscheinlich eher
futterqualitäten in diesem Jahr werden
die denn natürlich auch entsprechend
nicht so hoch vergütet werden nicht nur
die Qualität auch die Quantität hat
gelitten in ganz Deutschland bringen die
Bauern voraussichtlich fast 4% weniger
Getreide ein als im Vorsommer mit
41,9 Millionen Tonnen liegt die Menge
aber nur etwas unter den Durchschnitt
der vergangenen Jahre das
unterdurchschnittliche Ernte Ergebnisse
in Verbindung mit stark rückläufigen
Preisen wird natürlich die ökonomische
Situation der Betriebe belasten das
heißt die Geldmittel um die neue Ernte
finanzieren zu können die sind deutlich
geringer wie im letzten Jahr Landwirt
Heiko Terno hat seine gesamte
Getreideernte in dieser Scheune
eingelagert zur schlechten Qualität
kommen hohe Kosten für Dünger und Diesel
doch noch hofft er auf eine
ausgeglichene erntebilanz wir haben ja
auch noch Kulturen im Feldchen wie die
Kartoffeln die haben eine gute Qualität
die wer noch ordentliche Ertrag bringen
und da haben wir auch gute Preise so
dass sie durch die Anbau von
unterschiedlichen Früchten ich noch eine
Risikoverteilung habe und ich dadurch
auch noch hinbekommen werde den
Kartoffelknollen hat der regenreiche
Sommer gut getan doch hat er nicht
geschafft das wasserdefizit
auszugleichen in vielen Regionen ist der
Boden weiterhin zu trocken
und jetzt so hockeyheim em nach den
deutschen Frauen sind jetzt auch die
Männer erfolgreich in die Weltmeister
haben aber im ersten Spiel gegen Wales
nicht über ein Unentschieden
hinausgekommen gestern Abend aber gegen
Titel Verteidiger Niederlande einen ganz
ganz starker drei zu tun
direkt in der ersten Spielminute fällt
auch das erste Tor Justus Weigand trifft
so frühen Führung das 2:0 in der fünften
Minute lenkt ein Niederländer mit dem
Fuß ins Tor in der 28 Minute ist es dann
malte Hellwig der mit seinem zweiten
Turnier Treffer den 3:0 entstand
markiert wir wollten direkt Druck drauf
gehen und sie immer wieder stressen und
ich glaube das ist gerade am Anfang ganz
gut gelungen im dritten Gruppenspiel
gegen Frankreich reicht den deutschen
ein Unentschieden zum Weiterkommen ins
Halbfinale
Riesenüberraschung gestern Abend bei der
Leichtathletik-WM shakari Richardson aus
den USA lässt die hochfavorisierten
Jamaika Jamaika Rennen hinter sich und
gewinnt Gold über 100 Meter gina
lippenkemper hatte es nicht bis ins
Finale geschafft
für shakari Richardson ist es der erste
Titel die 23-Jährige aus Dallas läuft
wegen ihrer schwachen Vorlaufzeit auf
der ungünstigen Außenbahn mit 10,65
Sekunden ist sie dennoch so schnell wie
keine vor ihr in einem WM Finale und
gewinnt vor cherica Jackson und
Titelverteidigerin Shelly and Fraser
Preis beide Jamaika ins Finale läuft der
Frankfurter Joshua Abu Akku als erster
deutscher Läufer seit Harald Schmid vor
36 Jahren erreicht er den WM Endlauf
über 400 Meter Hürden
die deutschen Rennrodler Tony Eggert und
Sascha Benecken beenden ihre Karriere
das doppelsitzer-team hat 11
Weltmeistertitel geholt und 6 mal den
gesamt Weltcup gewonnen
erste Niederlage für die deutschen
Volleyballerinnen bei der heimwm in
Düsseldorf das Team Falle überraschend
gegen Schweden mit 1:3 hat aber
weiterhin Chancen aus Viertelfinale ja
und die fußball-weltmeisterin aus
Spanien sind wieder daheim und haben es
heute Nacht auf einer riesen Party in
Madrid mit tausenden Fans so richtig
krachen lassen und heute Vormittag wird
es dann aber feierlich Spaniens
Ministerpräsident Sanchez zeichnete die
Spielerin mit der Goldmedaille für
Verdienste im Sport aus
also erst WM Gold dann verdienst Gold
wirken aber noch ein bisschen müde für
mich das stimmt noch ist es ruhig beim
Wetter ab Donnerstag drohen Gewitter
mehr dazu hat gleich essen
Marietta Slomka begrüßt sie um 9:45 Uhr
im heute journal hier übernimmt morgen
Jana pareignis Ihnen noch einen schönen
Abend und auf bald
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter fast überall in
Europa gezogen Luftdruck und nur wenige
Wolken das sehen Sie hier auf unserem
Satellitenbild wirklich nur ganz wenige
Wolken unterwegs aber es gibt ziemlich
viel Hitze vor allem Richtung Spanien
Temperaturen über 40 Grad und auch das
Wasser selbst im Mittelmeer ist sehr
heiß teilweise rekordwarm wir schauen
auf die Nacht und da gibt's im Südosten
einzelne Schauer ansonsten gibt's Nebel
und nur harmlose bewölkerung und die
Temperaturen sinken auf 17 bis 19 im
Süden und teilweise 15 Grad ganz im
Norden am kühlsten Richtung hessisches
Bergland mit 12 Grad ja morgen dann
teilweise Quellwolken ganz im Süden an
den Alpen und daraus können sich dann
einzelne Gewitter entwickeln und Schauer
gibt's auch ganz im Norden dazwischen
aber häufig trocken viel Sonne bei
höchsten Temperaturen bis 35 Grad im
Südwesten hier eine extreme
Wärmebelastung ganz im Norden sind es 21
bis 23 13 29 Grad die nächsten Tage es
kommen Gewitter auf am Donnerstag Abend
die ersten kräftigeren ja und zum
Freitag müssen wir damit Unwettern
rechnen teils mit hagelsturmböen und
Starkregen ein schöner Abend